hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar entitled
laboratory medicine
and healthcare excellence until deaf do
us part
my name is trisha ravalico and i'll be
moderating today's session
on behalf of abbott and in partnership
with lab roots
i want to begin by thanking abbott for
not only sponsoring this webinar
but for leading the universal healthcare
excellence program which you'll be
learning more about today
if you have questions during this
session simply type them
in the ask a question box and click send
we will have time of course at the end
of the presentation as well
to hopefully address all questions
should you experience any technical
difficulties or have trouble viewing or
seeing the presentation
please also use the q a feature as well
for that type of support
it's now my privilege to introduce
today's speaker
dr colleen strain colleen
currently serves as a manager for global
scientific leadership at abbott
she is also on the executive leadership
team for the universe of healthcare
excellence program
she and i co-authored a paper just a few
months ago on this very topic
so she is a brilliant colleague a
standout champion for
lab medicine a recognized innovator and
is incredibly passionate about the topic
we'll be discussing here today
and in driving healthcare excellence
colleen the stage is yours
thanks trisha for the wonderful
introduction and welcome everybody
to our presentation today entitled
laboratory medicine
and healthcare excellence till death do
us cart
before we get into the fun stuff today i
did want to share my disclosure
trisha has already indicated that i of
course work for abbott
and have direct involvement in the
universe healthcare excellence award
program
which we will be discussing today so any
of the outcomes associated with these
best practices
have not had any independent
verification done by
admin
so today our topic is healthcare
excellence so what we'd like to ensure
that you learned today
is to be able to identify and understand
key themes
and success factors for healthcare
excellence
understand potential gaps and
opportunities for achieving
measurably better healthcare performance
and to inspire teamwork
and use of laboratory insights to
maximize benefits
for all stakeholders
and so why is this so important well
healthcare is changing we all know that
we have an
aging population consolidation of health
systems
necessitating everybody to do more with
less
even things like the covid pandemic or
forcing us to change
and of course we're now moving towards a
value-based
healthcare model and what this means
is that there are substantial
opportunities to provide
greater value and find innovative
solutions to
everyday healthcare problems and the
answer to how to do this
really is the lab
[Music]
and so why is the lab the answer well
because as
laboratories we all know there is so
much incredible and insightful data
within the laboratory that can really
help drive
new insights to enable decision making
and improved outcomes
across the key stakeholders now this
slide
in particular um is an incredibly
important slide and actually very hard
not to present
you know the entire presentation on just
this one topic as it is
a lecture unto itself but i think it's
really important
to cover this high level topic to
understand
some of those key decision making
drivers that the laboratory data can
present
which in turn can have substantial
impact on key stakeholders
for example laboratory data can
substantially impact
the way that patients are triaged and
diagnosed
which can have a huge impact on not only
their outcomes
but their mortality or even their
experience
we of course all understand the impact
that laboratory data has
on clinical decision making whether it's
related to
diagnosis prognosis or even treatment
this in turn can have a substantial
impact on not
only patient care but clinician
competence in the decisions that they're
making
looking at the health administration as
well clinical and laboratory data
can substantially change decision-make
decision-making processes
including what resources to use and
allocate
where which in turn offers opportunities
to optimize those resources
all of these decisions and all of these
changes can of course
impact cost and the payer whether it's
decisions to remove unnecessary
procedures
or opportunities to mitigate risks
and so all of these important decisions
and kpis
have really what is what brought us to
create
the universe of healthcare excellence
award program
which is a prestigious global award that
looks to replicate
emulate and celebrate best practices
of care teams around the world who have
unified
across the care continuum in new and
novel ways
to achieve a measurable benefit for
patients
payers clinicians and health systems
since starting this program there's
actually been over 36
recognized best practices across the two
years of the program
and there's been a substantial amount of
diversity in both focus
and expansion in geographical reach of
the program
and so i'm really excited today to share
some of those insights
and what we've learned
based on those 36 recognized best
practices
we'll be able today to walk through some
of the trends associated with
not just the program but trends we
believe that are truly happening in
healthcare
today and so it's associated with the
who
what where when and why and how of
healthcare excellence
so caregivers exist in medicine today
across
most disease states with opportunities
to improve
or expedite care regardless of disease
burden
it's not surprising however that
carotenes often focus
on areas with substantial unmet needs
enabling improved patient experience
reducing clinical uncertainty improving
staff satisfaction
and even lowering healthcare costs this
graph
here is from the world health
organization
which really highlights some of the most
prominent disease states
as it relates to all-cause mortality
which include
cardiovascular disease cancer chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease or copd
and type 2 diabetes all of which are
linked by common
and preventable or in some cases
preventable biological risk factors such
as high blood pressure
high cholesterol being overweight and
other major behavioral risk factors
and so action to prevent these chronic
diseases
often focus on controlling their risk
factors in a well-integrated
manner
and so across and between years the
disease states associated with the best
practices
of course vary um but they seem to focus
and
include many of those areas of high need
including cardiovascular disease kidney
disease
cancer diabetes and infectious disease
looking at this graph here you will know
that there is an absence
of recognized best practices in certain
key fields
including respiratory disease which is
something we just talked about such as
copd
being a major cause of mortality
worldwide there are also absences
of best practices in the areas of
fertility
and neurology and more and so these
current gaps are not likely driven by
say an absence of engagement
or even use of laboratory medicine in
these specialties
but rather an absence of award awareness
likely or
any lack of interdisciplinary
connections necessary to quantify
success
or ensure award eligibility and so
really this highlights
new opportunities for care teams to
further collaborate
and measure their impact on patient care
you'll also notice several other trends
here on this graph which we're going to
get into more detail
now
one of the major trends you'll see is
that there are substantial number of
infectious disease best practices
unsurprisingly the current covid19
pandemic
has necessitated new best practices in
the area of infectious disease
which has largely been driven by new
test method adoption
of the sars code 2 test method now as
you can imagine
there are several different very
interesting and impactful best practices
in this area
and i could spend several hours
discussing the amazing work that these
teams have done
unfortunately i don't have time to go
through them in as much detail as they
deserve
and so i invite everyone to check out
the universe healthcare excellence award
program
website for more details on these best
practices
and the best practices we discussed
today
outside of the realm of code 19 there's
also a
strong focus on infectious disease
related to hepatitis
hepatitis virus identification and
elimination
has continued to be a strong focus
across
both years of the award
and that really is actually unsurprising
as we all
or many of us are aware of the world
health organization goal
to eliminate hepatitis c and hepatitis b
virus
as a public health threat by 2030
and so impressively and despite the
global
pandemic that's currently ongoing these
best practices have continued to shine
and they vary in diversity across the
world which really speaks to the global
importance
of this these types of initiatives
now each initiative can vary and so
let's
dive into the details of one specific
initiative
from the 2019 awards program
this initiative uh hails from guys in st
thomas in the uk
and this integrated clinical care team
focused on identifying hepatitis b
and hepatitis c using opt-out screening
programs
in the emergency department and so this
integrated
clinical care team recognized that
despite the significant therapeutic
advances
in the management of hepatitis c and
hepatitis b
many of their patients remained
untreated and this was due to a lack of
either diagnosis or the logistical
barriers associated with actually
accessing care
and so they hypothesized that if they
could introduce both an education
and opt-out pathway within their
emergency department
that they could effectively reduce the
hurdles associated with accessing
not only diagnosis but timely treatment
for patients
who had undiagnosed disease and so what
they found was that when hbv
and hcv treatment and screening was
initiated
early in the disease process those
treatment options really could reduce
liver cirrhosis mortality and the
overall cost
on the health care system and so the
details of the outcomes of this
initiative
are both impressive and important and
something we're going to get
into a little bit later in this
presentation
so keep this best practice in mind as we
walk through
the next slides
another area and trend that you will
notice here is that cardiovascular
disease and kidney disease
continue to be strong focuses globally
and that's enough sir unlike some of
those emerging disease states
kidney disease and cardiovascular
disease
uh hail across both years of the award
and this is really unsurprising given
the data we saw
related to uh causes of mortality and
more de
morbidity and not who data and there
really are so many impressive and
diverse examples
in this space for achieving measures
that are healthcare performance
through the power of laboratory medicine
so for more details on each of these
specific best practices
i again recommend visiting the
university of healthcare excellence
website
as well as reviewing a recent issue of
the e-journal of the ifcc
which has a special issue on russia that
are healthcare
um that discusses some of these
initiatives in great detail
so let's dive a little bit deeper into
one specific best practice
that i suspect most if not everyone here
can truly relate to
so with the coven 19 pandemic in 2019
every health system around the globe was
trying to solve
not only for how to provide care for
patients with coven 19
but also how to ensure that areas of
critical need
continue to be available and that
patients felt safe
actually accessing the care that they
needed
and those areas included areas such as
cardiovascular services
as well as emergency care services
and so an integrated clinical care team
from new zealand
led by dr martin fenn a brilliant
emergency physician
at christchurch hospital really wanted
to
build upon their existing accelerated
diagnostic protocol
but instead not using the 99th
percentile
for high sensitivity troponin but by
mobilizing
outcome-based clinical cut-offs to
enable expedited triage for patients
presenting with chest
chest pain which of course is a symptom
of a heart attack
and what they wanted to do was ensure
that patients could
access the care that they needed and
safely be triaged
while reducing the amount of times
patients spent both in the emergency
department
and in the hospital to reduce the
opportunities for cross infection
and to achieve this they created a
comprehensive patient
streaming process so that patients at
low risk could quickly and safely be
sent home
without additional testing patients at a
medium risk or that one to five percent
risk for a major
adverse cardiovascular event could seek
follow-up care in an outpatient clinic
and then those with a higher risk
for a major adverse cardiovascular event
would be seen directly by the cardiology
team
and would have the standard zero to two
hour
serial measurement of your opponent
and so as you can imagine the outcomes
associated
with this initiative were substantial
and incredibly important
not just in the context of the covet
pandemic
but even beyond and so similar to our
last case study
we will discuss the impressive outcomes
and kpis
um associated with this best practice
but for those of you who are interested
in learning more
particularly about how they tackled how
when if serial measurements are
necessary in this case
i encourage you to review their paper in
the recent iej ifcc issue
on measured healthcare
another key trend that you'll notice
here is that
new disease categories for best
practices emerged in 2020
and that these best practices are not
necessarily exclusively focused
on those key top disease states that
we've already
discussed
and so while commonalities prevail
differences are noted
and areas of unmet need where laboratory
medicine
can play a role is truly substantial
looking at this list you'll notice one
of those areas of course
is diabetes more strategic
identification
and management of patients with known
and unknown diabetes
is an incredibly important topic to most
if not all countries worldwide and this
really relates to the question of
are we using the right test for the
right patient
at the right time to ensure that they
can get the
care that they need to improve their
health
and so many of those substantial costs
and poor
outcomes associated with diabetes are
often due in part to delayed diagnosis
and inadequate monitoring and treatment
of the disease
and so an integrated clinical care team
from alicante spain
led by dr maria salinas recognized an
opportunity
within their institution to implement an
i.t driven ordering system that could
improve
not just the detection and management of
patients with
diabetes and pre-diabetes but also
improve
the management of patients with known
diabetes
and the way they were able to do this
was they leveraged the power
of the laboratory information system to
automatically add an order
of hemoglobin a1c for patients without
known diabetes who met pre-set criteria
with this diabetes hemoglobin a1c
results
gps were now able to see if their
patients had known
or had unknown diabetes or pre-diabetes
and start the care care cascade
appropriately
a similar approach was taken for
patients with known diabetes
when a gp was doing any kind of
monitoring
for a patient with diabetes additional
tests
could be added by the laboratory
information system
in accordance with guideline recommended
monitoring
these the results from these additional
orders
would then trigger a gp to re-review a
patient care plan
based on these additional results that
they would not have ordered
without this integrated program and so
even with a basic understanding of
diabetes we can
surely appreciate the impact this can
have
on patient care patient outcomes and the
overall health system
and so with that we're going to jump
into a very interesting part of this
presentation which is a discussion of
the outcomes of these incredible
best practices
so the connection between laboratory
medicine and data
and measurement is incredibly strong the
irony however
is for as often as we as laboratories
work with
and love data and analytics we don't
often measure data
outside the lab we do linearity
precision etc but the impact of that
outside the lab is something that we
don't tend to have visibility to
and that lack of visibility to the
impact of the test
you know impedes our ability to
understand what to measure how to
measure it
and therefore understand actually what
good looks like
and so with that let's talk about a few
key options associated with
uh measurements these kpis or key
performance indicators
across key stakeholders that we tend to
talk about
these are of course only a few
representative examples
but you can start to see what some kpis
could look like within the scope of your
best practice
whether it's improving wellness or
experience for a patient
increasing confidence or decreasing
uncertainty for a clinician
increasing revenue or decreasing risk
in the health system or decreasing costs
through unnecessary or costly procedures
and so with these in mind let's look
back at our previously
discussed best practices and we can see
some of the trends
and kpis associated with them
and so from a higher level perspective
um and across the two years of best
practices
in the universe of healthcare excellence
or program the most frequently measured
kpi
in 2019 was increased clinical
confidence
and of course this is somewhat expected
um
as the power of laboratory data has long
been recognized for
value in guiding clinical decisions
however and
interestingly the most frequently
measured kpi
across recognized best practices in 2020
was decreasing health care costs which
actually surpassed the kpi
of clinical confidence that year and
this is really interesting because it
suggests that either
more teams have begun to more frequently
connect the downstream value of
laboratory medicine
beyond that clinical stakeholder or
perhaps they're just getting better at
actually quantifying it
and so let's talk about the easiest
stakeholder first as we can truly
appreciate the connection
between clinical decision making and the
laboratory
and so we all know that lab tests impact
clinicians
informatics can help as we saw from the
best practice in spain
and on the left here with this amazing
metric
and on the right in this case was
associated with the best practice from
new zealand
and is associated with a substantial
process improvement initiative
but you can start to see how this these
initiatives have truly impacted
clinician confidence when it comes
to decision making
reducing health care costs is also an
incredibly important kpi
by quantifying the value of the lab from
a monetary perspective
can be incredibly difficult although
equally important as some of the other
stakeholders take this example on the
left from the best practice
in new zealand we understand that this
process
involved largely reducing the number of
tests that were ordered
but the impact from a payer perspective
lives largely beyond
that of the lab you can see that the
cost savings associated with this
initiative
had a ripple effect with reduced ed
resource utilization
reduced hospital bed utilization leading
to
more than half a million dollars in
mitigated
annual costs similarly
for the guys in st thomas best practice
the cost savings associated with
mitigating disease progression
is substantial and lives far beyond the
cost of savings within the lab
within just the lab of course
and let's not forget about the patients
um it's not surprising that laboratory
tests drive decision making
in clinical care um and so the
on the left here the information
provided by the i.t
driven algorithm in alicante really goes
beyond that of say a traditional
diagnosis
diagnosis by providing additional and
new
insights and opportunities to treat
patients
improve outcomes and increase patient
wellness
and that's really a trend that you see
across so many of these best practices
that has such a substantial impact on
patient wellness
lastly let's discuss the impact of to
best practices that we've discussed
on the health administration some things
are actually
very difficult to measure um things like
staff satisfaction
but we can all appreciate that motivated
staff are more likely to go
above and beyond so don't underestimate
how much people want to contribute when
people
are united and feel they're doing a
really good job
that's incredibly important and through
that success
people are actually more likely to unify
and as people in healthcare we can
appreciate
that most people get into healthcare to
make a difference
and knowing that they're doing so can
actually be really rewarding
and i think you can start to get a sense
of that in this quote from guys in st
thomas on the right here
and so now that we've had a chance to
have a get a sense of
what outcomes look like and what some of
these integrated clinical care teams
have achieved the question is how how
have these
impressive care teams united to achieve
these
impressive and important health outcomes
and my answer to you is change of course
happens in many ways
the route taken to achieve a measurable
difference in health outcomes
will undoubtedly vary but success has
common commonalities which includes a
combination
of teamwork innovative thinking and a
commitment to drive change
and so we consider the single most
important impetus for change to fall
into three
broad categories one of which is the new
new information from new test methods
new insights gained from informatics
and strategic process changes to
existing infrastructure
and so in the space of new processes so
changing
a current infrastructure to change a
process we've actually already talked
about one
impressive best practice the one led by
dr san
in new zealand but and there are
substance
there are other substantial
opportunities as well for examples as
well
including um a beautifully simple
example
out of nova scotia that looked to
improve communication
of covid19 results to patients or even
maximizing patient care
through a comprehensive quality system
and so let's look at another example of
what a new process could look like
and so this best practice out of
palestine led by dr nahar
really sought to maximize patient care
through a substantial process change
through an improved quality system
and so looking at this slide we can
really all appreciate the spiral on the
left
as we can all appreciate that if we
don't invest in quality laboratory
medicine
there is a vicious cycle of lack of
resources
leading to decreased confidence under
utilization of lab tests
and thus affecting patient care and
further reducing
available resources and so by
establishing a process
change for a better quality system this
integrated
clinical care team actually
re-established clinical confidence
increased utilization of laboratory
resources and actually even had other
sites
sending them tests because there was so
much confidence
and they were able to substantially
improve patient care
which further enabled improvements to
resources
and strengthens their lab as a whole and
so looking at the right of the slide
here
you can see that that spiral is so much
bigger and that's really
related to the positive improvements
associated with the process change
for their better quality system
and it's unsurprising that such an
improvement to the process
has substantial change on many facets of
the health care system
this integrated clinical care team saw
substantial
annualized reduction in errors across
many test methods
which led to decreased maternal fetal
and childhood mortality rates
increased clinical confidence
optimization of resource
resources and decreased patient risks
so you can really appreciate how
improvements in process
although can look different can have a
substantial impact
on patient care and outcome
now this next bucket for a change driver
of implementation of new test methods
i'm sure is very super explanatory
self-explanatory to many here
but we can all appreciate that the
implementation of new test methods
requires widespread education demand
creation
and activation of consistent care
pathways
and this as laboratories is something
they do very well
implement new test methods when they
exist but the question really becomes
less about the test and more about how
you
implement that test into clinical care
for success
and on the screen here i do have a few
representative examples that
again we don't have quite enough time to
go through them in detail or do them
justice
um so you can explore them more on the
univons website
but what you can get an idea of is that
implementation of new tests
and even new applications of older tests
are important drivers obtained
outside of the laboratory
lastly and not least a significant
change driver
is the use of informatics it provides
substantial opportunities for synthesis
of data
either longitudinally or across
biomarkers at a single point in time
to enhance patient diagnosis monitoring
and or care and we've actually talked
about one brilliant example
already from only constant spain so
let's walk through
another example in which an integrated
clinical care team
has really leveraged and harnessed the
power of
the it algorithm to improve care
and this impressive example that we'll
be talking about is an
integrated clinical care project from
dundee scotland
led by doctors ellie dell and john
dillon who recognized
that the mortality rates associated with
one particular disease
liver disease were rising while the
mortality rates
for other diseases were decreasing and
so they really
saw an opportunity um
to to improve earlier identification
and treatment of this deadly disease
and so what they learned when the
hepatologists laboratories
it professionals and general
practitioners
um all got together was that liver
function
tests or lfts were actually being used
as
non-specific tests for wellness and that
often general practitioners
did not know how or what follow-up
should occur
should a patient's test come back normal
and so what they found
is that some patients were actually
having multiple liver function tests
across multiple years without that
follow-up that was necessary
to fully investigate why they actually
had
that abnormal result and so this
integrated team
actually sought to strategically
integrate
even more to improve the screening
and diagnostic process for these
patients
within primary care and this was
achieved by collaborating across
their continuum to develop a strategic
and novel
intelligent liver function algorithm or
ilst
that's based on guideline diagnostic
criteria
that actually leverages the power of
track analyzers to reflex
additional testing and then
uses real-time reporting to the clinical
staff particularly the primary care
physicians
with insights that will enable them not
only with insights related to
what their diagnosis was but also next
steps
whether it's a consultation to to a
specialist
or a specific treatment and so this in
turn has substantial impact
on not only identification of treatable
liver disease
but reduction of consultations to
general practitioners
as well as specialists it's a very cost
effective
tool as well as how truly helps patient
care
and so a few representative examples can
be seen
here so you can start to get an
understanding
of what a comprehensive it algorithm
can do for patient care it increased the
likelihood of a
correct diagnosis on first investigation
using an lft
um substantially from 41 to 93
it also increased the quality and
quantity of life
for patients and so patients actually
who had disease diagnosed early
had better outcomes and despite the
small
incremental diagnostic cause associated
with the additional reflexive testing
for the ilst algorithm the overall
reduction
in long-term costs associated with this
it algorithm
was substantial across patients and
expected to tally over
7 million pounds in within one year
and so what have we learned well we've
learned a great deal
but one of the things that really stands
out is that we need to be agile
and more importantly we need to be more
radical
and so more important than using say
informatics
is the power of new processes and while
new processes are not
always simple to implement they can
evidently have a significant
impact on patient outcomes clinical
outcomes
health system outcomes impair outcomes
but in order to achieve that measurable
difference
we absolutely need to work together
and so in conclusion lab medicine is
evidently the solution
to many healthcare problems that we see
today
whether it's new processes tests or
integration of new information
you are the answer so i encourage
everybody to leverage what you've
learned today
leverage these best practices and
you know if you're looking for more
information absolutely
leverage the resources that are
available to you from this webinar
and whatever the means to achieve
mentally better healthcare
and if you have already done so then
absolutely apply for universe
but either way i invite you to join me
in this pledge for healthcare excellence
not unlikely what we talked about today
it's lab medicine that will help protect
life
and so from this day forward for better
and not worse
in sickness and in health for patients
from the community
for unborn babies to the elderly to save
and to heal
i commit to health care excellence all
the days of my life
to be inclusive and innovative and being
open and strategic all while maximizing
the value
of laboratory medicine until death do us
part
thank you
colleen thank you so much for that
excellent presentation um
gosh there were a lot of insights shared
and i know a lot of topics to cover
we have a lot of questions i'm going to
start the
q a portion of the webinar now
for those that want to ask a question
that haven't done so already
please feel free to use the ask the
question box on the left hand side of
your screen
we'll aim to answer as many of the
questions as we have time for
but certainly i i do believe there might
be
if we don't get to all um those that
submitted questions will still be able
to get those questions
answered after the session concludes
with that i'm going to colleen start
with a few questions that have already
come
in um with the first one being
um if you need to be an avid
customer to apply for the universe of
healthcare excellence awards
it's a great question i love that people
are already thinking in that direction
and the answer is no you do not have to
be an avid customer
we encourage anybody who is achieving
actually better health care
and those who are unifying across the
care continuum
to absolutely apply this
program is not about products it's about
celebrating those care teams
who have really come together in unique
and avant-garde ways to to achieve
something better
so no you don't have to be an avid
customer
um you just have to meet some of the
minimum criteria which is focused
on collaboration and measurements
great um in fact actually i think even
the um
i think products are actually
discouraged um uh in the application
process
so good question um
is there a gold standard for a metric
collection
related to key performance indicators
that's a very good question and a tough
one i will say
i don't think there is necessarily a
gold standard associated with metric
collection
but i will share that the more
quantification of success
and connection of laboratory data
to laboratory impact
and the stronger kpis
will be and actually the more relatable
they will be
to your out-of-laboratory stakeholders
you know we as laboratorians appreciate
the the work that we do in great detail
and can understand that kind of ripple
effect and downstream
but that taking that next step and
connecting
um those insights and that data to
out of laboratory kpis
um is is an important step and there are
opportunities to quantify some of those
harder to collect kpis if you will um
whether it's through you know
comprehensive
review of databases or even use of
surveys
excellent um and what
what advice do you have for integrated
clinical care teams
who have not yet begun to
uh be part of projects like these how
and what would you recommend as the
first steps for them to get started
you know it's that's a that's a
wonderful question and one we actually
get
quite often because sometimes that's
really the hardest
step clinical care excellence of course
is something we all
strive for but it's not as easy as you
know let's do it and go
um and there's actually an interesting
interview
with some clinical experts that was
recently published in the e-news at the
ifcc
that actually discusses some of these
really interesting topics with some of
the key winners from the universe
program
and some of the insights that they share
is is really
starting to build a connection
with your out of laboratory stakeholders
even before you have a problem
um or even a solution that you want to
implement
is a k driver these clinical experts in
this case
you know highlight and appreciate that
you know laboratorians have what they
call
kind of a helicopter view of the health
system
and really provide you know insights
they didn't even know that they were
looking for
and so having that connection to the
clinical stakeholders
in particular is an excellent first step
to starting to integrate finding key
problems
and solutions and opportunities
for for healthcare excellence
that's great thanks thanks colleen
okay i'm just sorry i'm reading through
uh several of these questions um
uh another resource actually i'll just
add colleen
is is to learn from those who have done
it well right with some best practices
featured on the website
one question here is how people could
learn more about
some of those best practices that were
discussed today
absolutely absolutely and um again i i
love hearing that people are interested
in learning more about them and they're
so much more
complex than i was able to do them
justice for here
and so those interested in learning more
if you visit the universe website which
i believe is an available resource
for for everybody here when you're
watching this webinar
as well as if you type in
unimonthhce.com
you'll actually be able to learn more
about not just the winning best
practices
but all of the best practices across the
years
of the program um that's speaking not
only what they did
but the measurable impact that they've
had on their health system
and you can use these as inspiration
um and and even you know opportunities
to learn about what they've done or even
to understand
how people have measured in a scope or
or similar practice to which you are
hoping to do it
great so you discussed a lot about some
of the most frequently
measured kpis what are some of the
uh less frequent or atypical kpis
that may be difficult to measure but
have been stand out in terms of
performance
great great question um you know it's
it's funny you should ask a question
like that because i actually think some
of the
uh frequently used kpis are are some of
the ones that are actually quite
difficult
to measure in and of themselves
for example we often find that
connecting
these integrated best practices to
a you know concrete number of savings
for example
so associated with the payer metric and
reduced healthcare costs
is actually very difficult to do and not
necessarily a core competency that
um you know is that easy for most
because the cost savings are not only
so intricate but oftentimes you know
groups departments budgets etc are a
little bit
siloed so it's hard to actually quantify
that
despite it being a very important and
commonly used kpi
um other ones that are oftentimes
difficult or not as well used
are something as simple as say an
enhanced reputation
of a health system following the
implementation of such a best practice
and so we see different examples of this
across
best practices from as simple as
you know this is site recognized
in a newspaper uh or they've had
three other sites you know across the
country
what they've done for example the the
last best practice
that i that i discussed the intelligent
liver function testing algorithm
has actually been rolled out as i
believe the kind of standard of care
across
all of scotland and i think it's been
already implemented
in glasgow and so those ones are a
little bit harder to quantify
but equally important as some of those
more obvious and tangible kpis like
patient wellness or or what have you and
actually now that i see patient wellness
um that one can be
can be tough sometimes kind of
connecting that laboratory
uh piece of data to that downstream
um improved wellness for a patient
particularly for programs associated
with prevention right
um and so some of some of those ones can
be complex
and so that's why i think having a look
at what some of these integrated teams
have done
um through the examples on the website
is actually a really
important first step for for teams
looking to either replicate
apply learn more so you can start to see
what's
good looks like from a measurement
perspective great
great um there's
there's a comment here about
hospital-wide
health screening programs um and the
importance
of um putting in sometimes safeguards
or the question relates to how to put
safeguards
in place should abnormal results
put employees into sometimes unwanted
treatment tracks
that's a really um actually interesting
question and it kind of is the other
side of particularly
that those like i t um algorithms that
have additional testing right
because when a lot when a physician sees
a test or an abnormal test they are
obligated to act on it right
and so i think that there are certain
strategic
kind of faith cards that can be put in
place
and actually we didn't get into too much
detail in this case
but looking back on the diabetes best
practice
from spain the way that they were you
know able to
avoid kind of that over diagnosis over
testing over treatment aspect of things
was to not just you know from a
laboratory perspective
do this in a silo but to integrate
with their clinical team members to
ensure that the
you know testing algorithm that they put
in place
was clinically um appropriate
and that the input from that clinical
team could be used to build
the safeguards necessary so on the one
hand
absolutely you know much of the success
associated with these is
that integration right and having that
input from all those cross-positional
teams
and also making sure that you can you
know you physically have the
capabilities within
for example your lis and so that care
team in particular
um had kind of for lack of a better term
if statements built into their it
algorithm so
if hemoglobin a1c wasn't measured in the
last year
and this person's fit xyz criteria
do this and then it gave a suggestion
that recommended clinicians follow
certain considerations
um but it does require that clinical
input and so i
maybe some like a bit of a broken record
when it comes to the clinical input
um but it's a substantial piece for
ensuring that patients
do receive the right treatment because
you can't
do justice because doing a test doesn't
automatically equal better healthcare
and needs kind of that
downstream integrated approach from the
clinical
colleagues
thanks colleen in in terms of
these best practices and from from the
universe programs
um you mentioned 36 but there was each
year there's
there's three winners how are the top
winners selected
yeah great great questions so
uh the unimons program was uh founded by
abbott
but there are actually several
prestigious partners
associated with the program and are the
executive per the executive
team of uniforms and these prestigious
partners
actually are the judges so abbott plays
no role
in the judging process for unibus and
it's these prestigious partners that
span
across multiple different areas of
specialty
that are involved with actually scoring
and
judging and there's obviously
substantial
algorithms associated with how that's
that's all decided
um and so the more there's certain
criteria that gets you kind of
more points if you will um which include
you know the number of high quality
quantitative kpis um as well as the
impact
that it has and just for a little
background information
for for everybody the partners
associated with the program
are the ifcc so the international
federation of clinical chemistry and
laboratory medicine
the aacc the european health management
association
modern healthcare kim's the national
association for healthcare quality
the institute for health economics and
of it
and so those are really the prestigious
partners that are involved
with not just the strategic direction of
the program but in judging
of all of the best practices
that they weren't able to apply to the
awards for 2021
uh maybe you can comment a bit about um
the timing for
the next award cycle absolutely i think
it's excellent that someone's already
looking to apply
and it's actually just recently been
announced that the 2021 award cycle is
opening
actually august 1st so i
applaud you already for for thinking
through your application
um and getting ready to apply the portal
specifically for applying
is not open until august first but on
the universe website um
if you toggle over to the um
the login and register page there are
substantial
and really helpful resources that can
kind of guide you
through what's actually going to be
asked of you on in the portal itself
so you can actually although you cannot
submit your application yet
you can pre-prepare all of your metrics
your abstract
you know think through if you want to
have any supplemental material
etc um right now and so when that august
first date
opens you can submit your full
application and be ready to go
so for those of you who are interested i
actually
encourage you to start now think through
your kpis
what some of those metrics would look
like if you're not
at that point absolutely start kind of
that integration process
start speaking to your clinical
colleagues your i.t colleagues
management
administration so you can start
performing those
integrated clinical care teams so you
can solve some of those kind of
big health care problems within your
institution so
august 1st is the date
okay great and and what do you think uh
sorry yeah what do you think um the
biggest hurdle is
for laboratory medicine today what do
you think the next
version of uh these winners might look
like for
2021 great question
um tough to answer
i i expect to see a variety of different
best practices you know it there's
obviously
a huge number of disease states that can
be impacted
i of course expect to see you know best
practices across some of those many
disease states
i think you know before we hit the covet
19 pandemic
there were a lot of best practices that
really focused
on preventative care and so my
expectation and
really you know hope is that we'll
probably start to see a little bit more
of those
of course with covid we were a bit more
kind of reactive and
and that makes perfect sense but i think
you know fingers crossed as things start
to normalize
people will actually you know be able to
start viewing towards some of those more
proactive
health care uh strategies that focus on
prevention and maybe even screening if
you will and so we have seen
some wonderful and quite impressive best
practices
in those areas in the past and i expect
that trend to probably continue
terrific look there's there's about a
dozen
um questions still left but since we
only have five minutes
i i just wanted to say a few words um
first colleen i wanted to thank you for
your time today
also for your expertise your insights
and sharing your
important work um i also want to thank
labruz
for hosting this event and of course
abbott
on behalf of all the universe of
healthcare excellence partners i just
want to give a shout out to them as well
because
[Music]
i i strongly believe that this program
is bringing
to the forefront world-renowned
pockets of excellence where integrated
clinical care teams have really gone
above and beyond to not only
change health care and transform patient
lives
but to do so in partnership and in some
cases through the leadership
of laboratory medicine which is an area
that i know
all of us champion i also want to thank
the audience today
for joining and for their interesting
questions
um those questions that we didn't
complete today
uh there's again only about a dozen here
um
i will make sure that they get submitted
uh to the
to the authors of these questions um
through the on-demand period this
webinar will be available
on demand through labyrinths lab roots
will alert you via email
and then it will when it's available for
the replay
so we encourage you to share your email
or even share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
or may have questions and then to
colleen's point
i believe there's a handful of resources
that are also available
including her paper she mentioned the
e-journal of the ifcc
the special issue that was led by dr tim
james and dr ellie tat
ellie dao as guest editors both of them
are past
winners of the universe of healthcare
excellence program
so brilliant leaders in this space with
great
ideas there's even a conversation um on
the e news
uh ifcc newsletter uh that that
interview both of those health leaders
as well
um so there's a lot of information most
of these articles are all on the
universe program website as well
um it sounds like there's strong
interest in not just
the program but also in just driving
healthcare excellence
right colleen mentioned the date of the
new application cycle begins august 1st
so um that doesn't mean wait till august
1st to start your application
but it certainly means you can start
beginning submitting the 2021
applications in august so with that
i just want to say thank you to
everybody colleen
uh thank you again if you had any
parting comments i'll just pass the
floor to you
and then say goodbye
thanks so much uh trisha and thank you
everybody for joining
um i appreciate all of your questions
and
look forward to any feedback that's
provided through
the survey that will be coming your way
in just a few minutes so please
definitely take a moment to
to fill that out as we we value all your
feedback
your thoughts and if you do have any
questions
you can certainly reach out uh to myself
um
my my email should be available through
this this webinar
as well as reaching out to the universe
healthcare excellence at
abbott.com email if you have any
questions specific about the support
cycle
thanks so much